the jurogan experience there was another
disturbing
um moment where they were talking about
the rollout of the vaccine
and jamie who was that guy that was
he was advocating for not rolling it out
to elderly people because elderly people
are predominantly
white and that we should instead
do it give it to people that
are essential workers first because
essential workers
are more often people of color and that
this will balance things out like
literally say if more white people die
it'll be better because we'll have more
of a balance
this came from the cdc's advisory
committee responsible for deciding
who should get the vaccine yes first or
not
yes who is the guy that said it though
there was
one per and everybody blew a [ __ ]
gasket because that is really a creature
the problem is like i don't remember the
name of who said it but
all members of this advisory committee
supported it
except for one guy who was like
this is not based on science because if
you look at the statistics over 80
percent of people dying in this country
from covid
are people over the age of 65. yeah if
you want to save lives you would give it
and like 50 of people being hospitalized
over 65. so
yes if you want to save lives if you
want to make it so our icus aren't
like at max capacity then
give the va prioritize the vaccine based
on age
instead of occupation there is a concern
though that
essential workers are the ones who
spread it more easily because they have
to be encouraged i'm glad you mentioned
that
so it's not that cut and dry so these
essential workers that are
that are getting it like these folks
have to be at work
so they have to be at work they're more
likely to contract it if they get the
vaccine and they're protected from it
then it will spread less likely so
there's there's two things there first
is
is who the cdc designates as
an essential worker i'll get to that in
a second
but all of this is built on the
assumption that this vaccine will
prevent the transmission of the virus
which is what we're hearing from
some so-called health experts which
we're hearing from some in the media
it's not been scientifically proven
i've gone back and looked at the
applications that
um and the data that was put forward to
the fda to get approval from pfizer
and moderna and these vaccines have been
scientifically established
to uh largely prevent
serious health complications and death
from covid
once you're vaccinated that has been
scientifically established
nowhere in their trials was it
scientifically established that these
vaccines would prevent
the transmission of the virus and so i
i see it almost every day and it's
incredibly dangerous where
media outlets and some some people who
are
uh healthcare professionals are
propagating this
this i mean it's a lie it's not true but
they're basically saying that that well
you know people who have to go and work
in these jobs
um that are essential workers they need
to get vaccinated so they don't spread
it or
even you know first responders we had a
we had a local news station in hawaii
who shared a really
emotional interview from a first
responder
younger woman who had just gotten
vaccinated and she said
like finally i can go and visit my
grandmother
and not be worried that i am going to
um give her the virus because i'm taking
care of people who have covet every day
and what is so dangerous about that is
she got the vaccine if she has then gone
and visited with her grandmother
she could still and dr fauci's talked
about this and others
because this virus is is lives inside
your nasal passage
you can be vaccinated and you can still
pass it on
and it could have a a devastating effect
on someone for example who is elderly
uh and who is vulnerable to this and who
has not gotten the vaccine
so anyone who is saying that well we
have to vaccinate
these people or those people based on
their occupation
because we don't want the virus to
spread it has not yet it has not been
scientifically established
that the vaccines prevent that and this
is why they're all you know fauci and
these other guys they're like even if
you're vaccinated you have to still wear
the mask you still have to do social
distancing
uh because of the potential for that
so i think that's such an important
thing for people to know especially as
people are getting vaccinated
not to have this false sense of security
that
just because you've gotten the vaccine
now you can go visit grandma
in the nursing home because you're not
going to
expose her potentially or put her at
risk
but the second issue is is if you
actually go on the cds i've gone through
all the cdc slides that the advisory
committee put forward on
who is a frontline essential worker and
who's an essential worker
healthcare professionals and first
responders
obviously yes they are so overworked
they are over
taxed they should be getting the vaccine
right alongside
our elderly over 65. but if you start
getting past them and the people who are
listed as frontline
essential workers according to the cdc
you're talking about anybody who works
in manufacturing
anybody who works at a grocery store
anybody who works at a
oh gosh what were some of the other ones
uh in agriculture
in any sector basically you're talking
about
i don't know half of all working people
in front line essential jobs and then
you go on to the essential workers so
teachers and daycare workers they're
included in that as well and then you go
on to essential workers
people who work at banks people who work
in the media basically almost
everybody else who is in the workforce
as essential workers
so this goes back to the thing that you
originally said
is that part of their decision-making
process was this kind of justice
component and making decisions based on
who gets the
making decisions about who gets to the
vaccine first
not based on who is most likely to die
or get seriously ill but instead based
on
occupation um
it's i i kind of understand why you
would want
the people that are forced to work to
get vaccinated before people that are
not forced to work that makes sense
you know it's just
it's very difficult when you hear that
you're you're you want essential workers
to get vaccinated and they could still
spread it
because that seems to me to be that
needs to be
really expressed clearly very clearly
it's not being expected it is because
again you let's say you have that
example i mean you know
people over 65 my parents included like
you're you're pretty much stuck at home
yeah because of the day the very real
danger that if you go out and you get
infected you could die
yeah the danger of
this fact about how
the vaccines have not been
scientifically established to prevent
the transmission of the virus
that that's not being directly told to
every single person who gets it
is a real problem because then they go
home yeah
or they go and visit their parents who
they haven't seen for a long time or
their grandparents
and could be carrying the virus
and transmitting it unknowingly because
they think like
i'm good now right i'm safe and
and so that has to be part of this i
mean to me
there's a direct scientific correlation
based on facts
that if you look at the people who are
dying and who are being hospitalized
predominantly they are people over 65
years old
if we want to reduce those numbers those
are the people who should be prioritized
to get this limited number of vaccines
that we have
first then followed by
younger healthy people i mean it's to me
it's
and by doing that you know really we
could reduce the numbers
of covert related deaths by about 80
percent
reduce the numbers of covet related uh
hospitalizations by
i think it's like 48 49 that would
have a massive massive effect on
people's lives and and on our country
yeah well said and uh weird that that's
not
being said more often yeah i've i've
been
i've been pushing i've been pushing our
both our state leadership in hawaii and
also
also the trump administration so that
the trump administration uh
just in the last few days i think
it was at january 12th i think the
department of health and human services
did actually adjust their
recommendations
and they said vaccines need to urgently
go towards people over 65.
it is something that they have strongly
recommended to the states at this point
it's up to the states to choose
whether to implement it or not texas has
texas is one of those states that has
and there are a few others but at this
point
kind of the lives of our parents and
grandparents are in the hands of the
decisions being made by
the governors and state health officials
in each state
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience